welcome to this video playing psycho
cowboy from the UK Grandmaster Simon
Williams yeah I don't know maybe it's a
tech frustrated no I have I have played
him four times on the ICC end I won all
four games yeah jeezum is a super strong
technical and and aggressive player but
sometimes he's taking a Liberty is a bit
too far so strategically speaking in
place very risky sometimes and I made
good use of that and in the earlier
games huh interesting
it just looks like fairly standard
position besides the fact that he has
played g5 instead of the pong being on
g6 ok yeah one general ideas to take try
to grab the pawn but this would give him
very good play on them on the dark
squares and so I'm not sure I want to do
that I go for 4-h for him form using
this somewhat weakened kingside okay so
I'm going to cheat with the rook I guess
keeping keeping the the good structure
yeah if it is not able to play a five at
some point interesting okay this makes
sure that the knight absolutely will not
be taken okay Bishop here
controlling a fire that's that's quite
nice however it's not so clear how I'm
going to make any progress maybe Queen
d3 long castles book h1 satirically
speaking black isn't in some trouble
yeah maybe you can get this in the shop
g5
maybe but still if I go Queen I can take
h6 but this would give him some activity
I don't really know if I want to do that
I rather improve the position and if I
am take now take age 8 and cancel long
this is just just keeping a very nice
position with rook h1 coming ooh h1 Luke
h5 we cannot castlelong but you can take
a Kia you can play King to e7
yeah that's not not super great for me
this position that it is it is ok no no
no no doubt but it's not like I'm
winning or anything
Knight d1 III could be a way to improve
matches
the night only three is nice but it's
not so clear what what it is doing next
this knight on d4 is it's a very very
nice piece of course you would like to
activate this strange piece yes this is
a interesting he does not want to keep
it there forever but I can actually just
grab the pawn now can I not it's this
the drawback Queen takes g5 I don't see
it it's the drawback I don't want to
blunder something he didn't didn't see a
an issue here even f4 is a move as I
said is pinned but maybe maybe here and
he's going maybe it's going Knight f4 or
something I don't know I definitely
should try to be be to be to be with
KUKA here takes takes and he's going
that's not that's not as great check
here and drop back to h4 maybe check
night he's got 93 check that's that's
annoying
ah this move ah okay didn't think of
that
in 92 the ìiî ìiî am cheap Trick's
this is how this game is going time
warning
I will catch one how do I actually not
lose the rook something like that
probably that these are totally screwed
up
wasn't so easy to screw up but I managed
night F to at least little threat but he
can still take a form
I was thinking take taeguk f2 trying to
activate stuff
check
it's got Luke no I cannot go there bro
q1 it's still it's still possible due to
night f2 my project to do this check
very weird stuff and of course totally
unnecessary from the from the outset
maybe I can get connect I promote the D
pawn maybe it's probably just about
right in time but in 30 seconds it's
difficult to to not try it
hmm 66 Oh does she stop it
idea I don't see it maybe something was
checks okay I'm going to take take here
first
no I wanted to take on the six of moss I
shoot maybe maybe some something still
possible Christ how unnecessary was that
the source stuff I've got 18 seconds
check
I'm actually getting a draw I can try
puh puh from this totally dead end game
ah what a weird game what a weird game
yeah I of course I spoiled this around
here why does just winning this check
this wasn't factor I can take d6 oh I
totally overlooked that I can just take
d6
wow I was a bit shocked because I really
have we looked King g5 and okay I could
just take here and that's it white is
clearly better Here Come compass on + +3
almost you cannot take him I mean it
can't Jack it's also very good yeah but
probably I should try some approach that
he couldn't really stand to have the
knight on h8 a queen a5 and the compass
totally merciless Queen a5 Queen takes a
7 + 3 it's possible I mean he does not
really have anything the knight on d4 is
not even threatening a check and I mean
quite some control on the Queen side on
the Kings side better carriage so I know
take the pawn just it's just a pawn
ready here Andrew Paige 6 I played it a
play played it ok check only here I I
went a stumble of course I'd here this
must be good for him pretty sure was
this with this great activity in Brooke
h8 King D - King f3 King takes d4 strong
ok
but yeah there must be a loss at
check-check yeah this is losing chess is
losing it takes excited to diss it is
losing
I was just he shouldn't take it seems f5
wins Wow very strong move by the come
Priya very strong black gets and gets a
passer the e pawn this is super strong
promoting and I'm playing without the
knight on h1 of course very strong stuff
this after E 5 is still the game okay -
one point something probably lost but it
not like I would buy McQueen down and
here in fact I'm okay again amazing but
ok it was a was very little time this
seems to be best check like getting a
queen as well and wins okay yeah and of
course I made them basically Mouse that
I wanted to take here and then we
continue with this position which should
be at least okay from me equal I guess
but I made a mouse slip here with these
six cent this is now just lost but he
failed to try this little little trick I
can even take check and here okay
it was a very lucky draw okay okay this
this black should definitely win but
it's a check not totally easy to do with
with very little time
somehow I managed to get all the pawns
yeah it was serving you in full black ok
thanks for watching